in terms of using certain footage versus
not using what was your test to know
this isn't going to work it's great i
love it but this for the film it just
won't work this is the hardest hardest
part and that's where you need a great
editor and i was fortunate to have a
great editor Edward Osage Emma who was
named in the new york times review as a
brilliant editor deserves that back lied
you know we have probably 300 hours of
footage between interviews and stock
footage and stills and performances and
Edward and I talked a lot about
structure about how we saw this about
how it was defined in a three-act format
and this again is where my formal
training comes in you know I have a real
sense of beginning middle and end and
narrative structure and threads that
weave through and Edward and I talked
about this about where I saw the first
act ending where I felt the second act
ended what the third act was and what
the narrative threads were through the
whole thing which as you know racism
comes into it and the woman women's
struggle comes into it and the music
world comes into it so we had a pretty
good meeting of the minds about what the
thematic things of the film would be and
what the structure would be and then I
gave everything to Edward and said ok
start cutting and he would come to me
every day with pieces that he had cut
and you know some of them I would just
be in heaven with what he had done other
ones I didn't think they quite worked
other things I wanted in he fought
against other things he thought were
really good I fought against we had a
really creatively combative situation
which I find to be the best way to work
with somebody else you know not that
everybody not that your editors says
everything you want is wonderful but
that your editor has
creative ideas of their own and that was
the process and that was the most
enjoyable process the editing process
was just really fabulous so your editor
should not be a yes man or woman exactly
they should you know assert themselves
exactly someone yeah how can you tell
though somebody wants complete control
of it and how do you find that balance
what if they're not listening to you if
they're not hearing what you're saying
and they're coming back with something
that has nothing to do with what you
asked for then you know you've got the
wrong editor but with Edward whatever he
came back with was what I asked for and
more so I thought oh my god you know
he's taking this to places that I hadn't
even envisioned and that's that's what
you want from your editor